hey y'all today i'm going to show you
guys how to make the start menu
that orange button right there
i'm going to show you how to make that
the shutdown button right now it's the
sleep button
so
first thing we're going to do i've
written it all down here so you guys can
follow along it'll be in the description
we're gonna go start
control panel
hardware and sound
wait for this to load
i'm gonna find hardware and sound
you probably find it before i do oh wait
classic view
here we go control panel home
go to hardware and sound
go to power options just click power
options
and i want you to go to change plan
settings for whatever setting you are on
from here you go to change advanced
power settings
and you're going to expand
the menu that says start menu
you're going to expand power buttons and
lid
and you're going to expand power button
action now you're going to start mini
power button
that's the button that we're trying to
change
on battery
change it to shut down
that's all you got to do
plugged in change it to shutdown
apply
hit ok
and you've got to shut down that much
quicker so now
when i hover over it it's red and it'll
tell me this is going to shut down
windows and turn off my computer
so that is how you change
that's how you change the start menu
power button to shut down from the
standard sleep in windows vista if you
like this tutorial subscribe more to
come peace